>> Chris: MARK BARRETT OF
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARK, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, TREASURY
SECRETARY STEVEN MNUCHIN, WHO IS
A MEMBER OF THE PRESIDENT’S
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE.
MR. SECRETARY, WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
>> Secretary Mnuchin:
THANK YOU, CHRIS, IT’S GOOD TO
BE BACK WITH YOU.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
THAT ONCE THE COUNTRY REOPENS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO SEE A
SHARP, QUICK RECOVERY.
HERE HE IS THIS WEEK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO REBUILD IT
AND WE ARE GOING TO REBUILD IT
BETTER AND IT’S GOING TO GO
FASTER THAN PEOPLE THINK.
BUILD IT ONCE, I’LL BUILD IT A
SECOND TIME.
>> Chris: HOW SHARP A RECOVERY
DO YOU SEE AND HOW SOON, SIR?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: I THINK
AS WE BEGIN TO REOPEN THE
ECONOMY IN MAY AND JUNE YOU WILL
SEE THE ECONOMY REALLY BOUNCE
BACK IN JULY, AUGUST, SEPTEMBER
AND WE ARE PUTTING IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF FISCAL
RELIEF INTO THE ECONOMY.
YOU’RE SEEING TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT’S MAKING ITS WAY
INTO THE ECONOMY AND I THINK
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
>> Chris: BUT THAT QUICK
BOUNCE BACK THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
GOES AGAINST THE FORECAST OF
MOST EXPERTS, AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THESE NUMBERS, SIR.
THE NONPARTISAN CONGRESSIONAL
BUDGET OFFICE NOW PROJECTS GDP
WILL SHRINK BY 5.6% TOTAL THIS
YEAR.
UNEMPLOYMENT WILL END 2020 PER
PAYCHECK AND YOUR FORMER
COMPANY, COPELAND, GOLDMAN SACHS
IS THE OVERHEAD WILL BE FOUR
TIMES WORSE THAN THE 2008 GREAT
RECESSION.
QUESTION, ARE ALL THOSE
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS WRONG?
THE TWO WELL, WE’VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
THIS IS NOT A FINANCIAL CRISIS,
THIS IS THE NEXT SCENARIO WERE
WITH CLOSED ECONOMY AND WE’RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ECONOMY SO ALL
THESE MODELS ARE BASED UPON
HEALTH ASSUMPTIONS, HOW QUICKLY
WE REOPEN.
SO WE WILL SEE.
MY OWN OPINION IS, AGAIN, WE
HAVE UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF
LIQUIDITY IN THE SYSTEM.
WE ARE VERY EMPATHETIC TO ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT OF WORK,
BUT THERE IS ENHANCED ON
EMPLOYMENT, THERE’S THE PPP, AS
DIRECT DEPOSITS.
THIS IS GOING TO PUT A LOT OF
LIQUIDITY AND AS BUSINESSES
BEGIN TO OPEN YOUR GOING TO SEE
DEMAND SIDE OF THE ECONOMY
REBOUNDS.
>> Chris: LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
PPP.
THE PRESIDENT JUST SIGNED A BILL
THAT CONGRESS HAD PASSED,
ANOTHER $310 BILLION FOR THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM, BUT
THE FIRST ROUND, I THINK IT WAS
250, $300 BILLION.
THE SIGN UP FOR THAT RAN OUT IN
13 DAYS.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK THIS NEXT
TRANCHE, $310 BILLION, IS GOING
TO LAST AND CAN YOU GUARANTEE
THAT BIG CORPORATIONS, FOR
INSTANCE LIKE ROOTS CHRIS, THAT
GOT MONEY THE FIRST TIME AROUND,
EVENTUALLY PAID IT BACK, BUT DID
GET MONEY, WON’T EVEN GET MONEY
THIS TIME?
>> I JUST WANT TO PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE AND I WANT TO THINK
EVERYBODY AT THE SPA AND THE
TREASURY AS WE LAUNCHED A
BRAND-NEW PROGRAM IN INCREDIBLY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AND THE
FACT THAT WE RAN OUT OF MONEY
JUST GOES TO SHOW THE SUCCESS OF
THIS.
LET ME PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE.
IN THE FIRST ROUND, OVER A
MILLION COMPANIES HAD WORKERS OF
TEN BELOW -- THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF FOCUS ON THESE BIGGER
COMPANIES, PUBLIC COMPANIES.
WE CAME OUT WITH NEW GUIDELINES,
MADE IT CLEAR THEY SHOULDN’T
HAVE APPLIED.
THEY’RE PAYING BACK THE MONEY,
SO I THINK YOU’RE GOING TO SEE
THIS MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND I THINK YOU’RE GOING TO ALSO
SEE IN THIS ROUND THE AVERAGE
LOAN SIZE GO DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY.
>> Chris: BUT TO MY OTHER
QUESTION, WHICH WAS THAT THE
MONEY FOR THE FIRST PROGRAM
LASTED LESS THAN TWO WEEKS, HOW
LONG DO YOU EXPECT THIS MONEY TO
LAST?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
TO ME IT’S NOT A MATTER OF HOW
LONG IT LASTS.
THE ACTUALLY -- I THINK THE
SOONER THE MONEY IS DISPERSED
THE BETTER, SO THE FIRST ROUND
IMPACTED ABOUT 30 MILLION
WORKERS.
I THINK THIS ROUND WILL BE ABOUT
THE SAME.
THAT WILL BE CLOSE TO 50% OF THE
PRIVATE WORKFORCE BY ACTUALLY
HOPE WE RUN OUT OF MONEY QUICKLY
SO WE CAN GET TO THE MONEY INTO
THE WORKERS’ POCKETS.
AND IN THIS ROUND WHERE MAKING
IT CLEAR THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE ACCESS.
WE SIGNED UP A LOT OF CPF IS.
WE ARE SIGNING UP MORE OF THEM
SO WE ARE GOING TO TAKE SURE
THIS DISTRIBUTIVE FAIRLY.
>> Chris: CONGRESS IS ALREADY
TALKING, WITH ALL THE MONEY
THAT’S ALREADY BEEN DISPERSED,
TALK ABOUT YET ANOTHER RELIEF
BILL AND ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES
THERE IS WHETHER OR NOT TO GIVE
$500 BILLION IN RELIEF TO STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO PAY
FIRST RESPONDERS AND OTHER
WORKERS ENTER PROVIDE SERVICES.
THIS WEEK SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL AND NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO SPLIT
SHARPLY ABOUT THAT, TAKE A LOOK,
SIR.
WE GO I WOULD CERTAINLY BE IN
FAVOR OF ALLOWING STATES TO USE
THE BANKRUPTCY TO SAVE SOME
CITIES.
>> HE SAID MAYBE THE STATES
SHOULD DECLARE BANKRUPTCY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE REALLY DUMB
IDEAS OF ALL TIME.
>> Chris: DOES THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORT GIVING AID, HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, TO THE
STATES, AND WHAT WERE THE
ECONOMIC EFFECT TO BE IF MAJOR
STATES LIKE NEW YORK AND
ILLINOIS WERE TO DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS, I
FIRST WANT TO JUST SAY, I REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE SENATE AND THE
HOUSE FOR THE UNPRECEDENTED AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THE BILL FIRST PASSED 96-0 AND
THIS ONE WAS UNANIMOUS CONSENT
IN THE SENATE SO MY COMMENTS ON
THIS IS THIS WILL BE SOMETHING
THAT BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
HOUSE DEBATE.
IT WILL BE SOMETHING THAT WE
DISCUSSED ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HEARD FROM
GOVERNMENTS, HE WANTS TO SPEAK
TO GOVERNORS.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE WILL
CONSIDER BUT OUR FOCUS RIGHT NOW
IS REALLY ON EXECUTION AND
THAT’S WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON
AND IF WE NEED MORE MONEY, AS
I’VE SAID, THIS IS A WAR, WE
WILL WIN THIS WAR.
IF WE NEED TO SPEND MORE MONEY
WE WILL AND WE WILL ONLY DO IT
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, LET ME
PICK UP ON THAT LAST POINT
BECAUSE WITH ALL OF THE MONEY
THAT’S ALREADY GONE OUT, THE
NATIONAL DEBT WILL, BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR, EXTEND EXCEED THAT
DOMESTIC PRODUCT.
THE TOTAL OUTPUT OF THE ECONOMY,
OVER 100% OF GDP, WHICH HAS
ALWAYS BEEN CONSIDERED A KIND OF
REDLINE FOR STABLE ECONOMIES.
MUCH DO YOU WORRY ABOUT A DEBT
IN EXCESS OF 100% OF GDP?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT INTEREST RATES ARE
EXTREMELY LOW, SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE PORTION OF THE BUDGET THAT
WE ARE ACTUALLY ALLOCATING TO
INTEREST, IT’S EXTREMELY LOW AND
WE ARE LACKING IN LONG-TERM
RATES TO MAKE SURE THIS
ADDITIONAL MONEY WITH LOCKED UP
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
OVER TIME, THAT IS SOMETHING
WE’RE GOING TO NEED TO LOOK AT
AND WE ARE GOING TO NEED TO LOOK
OUT OVER TIME HOW WE DEAL WITH
THAT ISSUE, BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
IN A WAR AND WE HAVE TO PROTECT
AMERICAN WORKERS AND AMERICAN
BUSINESS AND WE ARE GOING TO DO
WHATEVER WE NEED TO TAKE TO DO
THAT.
>> Chris: IN THE TIME WE HAVE
LEFT I’D LIKE TO DO A LIGHTNING
ROUND.
I’VE DONE YOU WITH THESE BEFORE,
QUICK QUESTIONS, QUICK ANSWERS.
WE SEE STATES STARTING TO
REOPEN.
IF THEY REOPEN TOO QUICKLY, IF
WE SEE A SPIKE IN CASES, A
SECOND SPIKE, HOW DAMAGING WOULD
THAT BE TO THE ECONOMY?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: I THINK
WE HAVE TO BALANCE THIS IN THIS
TIME WITH THE ADVENT WITH THE
ADVENT OF MORE TESTING,
ANTIBODIES, I THINK WE ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MONITOR THIS VERY,
VERY CAREFULLY.
>> Chris: WILL THE
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ALLOWED OIL
COMPANIES -- BAILOUT OIL
COMPANIES BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
THERE ARE SOME CRITICS WHO SAY
THERE ARE PROBLEMS THAT CAME
FROM THE CORONAVIRUS AND THE
GLOBAL DROP, BUT A LOT OF
PROBLEMS OF OIL COMPANIES WERE
UP THEIR OWN MAKING BEFORE WE
EVER GOT INTO THIS PANDEMIC.
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR THE
PRESIDENT SAID NO BAILOUTS TO
ANY COMPANIES, WHETHER THAT WAS
AIRLINES OR OIL COMPANIES.
WE WILL CONSIDER, AGAIN, LOANS
TO COMPANIES IN A PROPER
SCENARIO, STRATEGIC IMPORTANCE
BUT NO BAILOUTS, NO SHAREHOLDER
BAILOUTS.
>> Chris: AND WOULD YOU
CONSIDER LOANS TO OIL COMPANIES?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THAT WE
WOULD AND WE’RE LOOKING AT IT
CAREFULLY.
THE SECRETARY OF ENERGY AND I
ARE STUDYING IT AND WE’RE
LOOKING AT IT VERY CAREFULLY.
>> Chris: FINALLY, SOME TOP
REPUBLICANS ARE TALKING ABOUT
GOING AFTER CHINA TO PUNISH THEM
FOR THEIR FAILURE TO BE MUCH
MORE TRANSPARENT AT THE VERY
START OF THIS PANDEMIC AND IN
FACT, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
MISSOURI HAS ALREADY SUED CHINA.
HOW DO YOU BALANCE, ON THE ONE
HAND, WANTING TO HOLD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE FOR MUCH HOLD HIM
RESPONSIBLE, BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND, WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC, WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A GLOBAL ECONOMIC CRISIS,
WANTING TO PROTECT GLOBAL
MARKETS, ESPECIALLY GLOBAL
TRADE?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WELL,
FOR THE MOMENT WE NEED TO WORK
GLOBALLY TO CONQUER THIS VIRUS,
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE VERY
CLEAR HE WANTS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT CHINA KNEW, WHEN THEY KNEW
IT AND IF THEY KNEW THINGS THAT
THEY DIDN’T TURN OVER THAT COULD
HAVE STOPPED THIS, HE WILL HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Chris: SO AT THIS POINT,
CAN YOU SEE SANCTIONS, STRONG
ECONOMIC ACTION AGAINST CHINA?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: I THINK
YOU KNOW WE NEVER MAKE COMMENTS
ON FUTURE SANCTIONS OPTIONS.
>> Chris: WE ARE GOING TO
LEAVE IT THERE, SECRETARY
MNUCHIN, THANK YOU.